hello folks
welcome to
rational science directly from frankfurt
germany
and the only site on the internet that
does
physics
everybody else does
mathematics
what is mathematics
irrationality
all they have is irrational explanations
for every phenomenon
in which invisible intangible entities
serve as mediators
and so we need to define what
irrationality is or in this case so that
we can follow along right
and here's the definition we have
and primarily it's that first one okay
so we don't have to go through all of
them but creating concepts as objects
using words such as energy field
uh wave
charge mass
to care to explain a physical
mechanism it's irrational you can't use
a concept
and it's like saying you're gonna use
love or you're gonna use um
uh i don't know intelligence
uh very little of that in cambridge
anyways that's the the primary
definition moving concepts around that's
what all these mathematicians do
okay we don't care about their math we
don't care about their equations their
predictions their observations what we
care about is what's the bottom line
what explanation do you have for gravity
what explanation do you have for
magnetism
what's the mechanism
if you cannot give me a mechanism
you are not a physicist
you are a
an irrational mathematician that's all
you are
that does equations
descriptions that's all an equation does
and so
another issue that we have against the
mathematicians is the word hypothesis
not a single mathematician's ever
discovered what a hypothesis is
mathematicians think that a hypothesis
is a theory an unproven theory a
tentative
theory
no that's not what a hypothesis is so
we're gonna have a difference with them
and these are the definitions you'll
find on the internet for hypothesis
objectives
one says it's a purpose another fellow
says it's a question
another one says it's a tentative guess
these are all official by the way okay
uh assumptions
another file says it's evidence testing
another one says a theory a provisional
theory tentative theory
predictions
so what is a hypothesis it's all of
those is an assumption the same thing as
a prediction
is a theory the same thing as an
assumption
so this is where we have a problem these
people have no idea what a hypothesis is
is they never define the term
okay and they just use it
and so we criticize not only the fact
that they have irrational explanations
they also have
irrational notions of what a hypothesis
is and what the purpose of the
scientific method is
and we had this fellow uh and he uh
made a video 45 minute video
uh criticizing my notion of science
okay and i think it came in very handy
partly because i was doing the videos
okay
i was uh in the process of doing some of
these videos talking about science he
criticized like six or seven of them i
don't remember how many have got up
there
and um
and so he criticized them and i'm gonna
analyze point by point that he made i
think it's good that he did it uh in
great measure because 99 of the people
out there believe just like he does they
have the same
they went to the same monastery and they
learned the same
i call it the mathematical method they
call it the scientific methods got
nothing to do with science okay and
today we're going to show that
we're going to show that his method
fails completely okay hopefully we can
uh find out
you know whether he's even in the
ballpark
okay so uh this is what this fellow said
with respect to what i'm going to talk
about today again i'm going to be
analyzing point by point today
we're going to look at a
couple points and these are the points
okay
here let me give me a second here let me
prepare it okay
and here it goes listen tight there we
go
questions and issues addressed in this
rebuttal include this fellow claims that
discovering the nature of gravity is
very difficult and that the
mathematicians don't have all the
answers
then he contradicts himself by asserting
that the mathematicians have already
figured out the mechanism of gravity
specifically the answer to why the moon
doesn't fly out of the solar system
so
which is true
because it's not exactly easy you don't
just drop something go
oh that fell i guess it's invisible
green pixies then
so
why haven't the mathematicians who call
themselves physicists figured out the
extremely simple mechanism of gravity
after 2 500 years of research
experiments and math
this fellow replies
that the mathematicians don't yet have
all the answers
that might be because we don't have all
the answers yet
science can answer those questions it
just may not be fully complete yet
but then in the same breath he boasts
that the mathematicians do indeed know
the cause of gravity
that all you are required to do from now
on is memorize and repeat what they have
already discovered
well that's because earth being space
time
and bent space time can alter the 3d
trajectory of an object so that question
has been answered
maybe try taking a science course
okay
so uh he says he doesn't know what
gravity is he drops something for
example in this case a spoon
he doesn't know
why that falls
says no mathematician mathematician i'm
sorry on earth can tell you that
they all have all these equations they
did all the experiments ever
thought about no one can explain why
this spoon
falls to the earth we have two objects
the earth and the spoon not a single
mathematician
not a single idiot at any university on
the planet
can tell you why what causes
this spoon to fall to the floor
okay that's the issue
okay so here we go
here's a here's what this fellow
believes he believes that the moon rolls
around space time warp time he says that
there's something called time
a physical object that is bent
okay that's what he says okay here it is
this is what he believes in this is what
he was taught in high in high school or
at the monastery you know this is where
the altar boys get you know their
information
of how i mean this ridiculous thing is
what these people believe in and 99 of
the people out there believe in this
garbage this nonsense this poppycock
okay this is what they say science is
okay so here we have um
you know uh the the notion that they
have out there again a different version
of it uh
warp space time is that what they call
it what time bent time as he says
okay so so we have bent time great and
this is nasa this is the official
version okay there you see it and you
can see the caption there gravity probe
be measured how gravity warps space and
time
okay so
everybody says the same thing and they
illustrate it i mean there should be no
no reason not to doubt this nonsense
coming out of nasa because all these
phds in mathematics right they tell you
in your face that it's warped space and
time and you're staring at it now i
don't know what part you would not
understand when you you're staring at
what they're saying they're saying that
time is work that time is bent okay
and uh and then when you question them
then they put this cartoon to ridicule
you they say understanding gravity space
time is like this rubber sheet massive
objects distort the sheet and
and a student says they distort it
because they're pulled down by what
and the other fellow immediately changes
the subject says space-time is like this
set of equations
for which any analogy must be an
approximation
well we have a little bit of problem
because this is not this is what they
illustrated and we need to explain why
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system okay and these people are telling
you that
the reason is that
the earth which is a three-dimensional
solid you know quite solid you know you
can
sit on it you jump on it right
and they're saying that that big object
called
uh earth or any planet even a moon why
it doesn't leave the solar system is
because time is bent
now what sense does that make
and you might say bill that's not what
he said
let's hear it again let's make sure we
all understand what this individual said
and what everybody out there believes
let's put it one more time just for your
amusement okay here it goes okay give me
a second
well that's because earth bends time and
bend time can alter the 3d trajectory of
an object
time
can alter the 3d trajectory of an object
time
can alter the 3d
tree of an object
did you hear it correctly or did i
lie
the guy said bent time and that's what
prevents the earth from flying out of
the solar system
this is the nonsense that these altar
boys learn at the cambridge monastery
or at nasa or
cern or who knows where
this is the nonsense that is out there
it's ridiculous nonsense that has
nothing to do with science or physics
okay so he says he doesn't understand
or no mathematician no math magician on
earth can tell you why this spoon
falls to the floor okay
and let's look at this let's look at
this simple
simple very simple issue that no one has
been able to solve in 10 000 years why a
spoon falls to the floor i mean how
difficult can that be we've got a spoon
and we have the earth
you don't like that you like an
astronaut and the earth
you don't like that you like the moon
and the earth
two objects no matter how you look at it
two objects okay here we have the spoon
and the earth no one on earth can tell
you why that spoon falls to the earth
let's look at it okay here we go
this is the spoon falling down to earth
and so you say well why does a spoon
fall to earth
i mean why why does it fall upwards
towards the sky towards the ceiling why
does it fall to the floor
okay
important question
okay so this fella says well i can do it
with pixies green pixies
so i didn't know what a pixie was
exactly i mean i had an idea but i
looked it up and these are the two
notions that are out there one the green
pixies are these uh peter pan like uh
gnomes or whatever that are flying
around okay we can do it with that and
we have the other green pixies where
it's just particles okay so we have
these two notions i'm gonna go with uh
the one on the right and you can replace
each one of those dots with the green
pixies on the left no problem whatsoever
okay so here uh i want to know the
mechanism of breath of green pixies i'll
i'll let him i'll let him simulate
gravity with his green pixies he can
choose any green pixies he wants okay
here we go
are the green pixies pushing
the spoon downwards is that how gravity
works is this what he's going to explain
or is it that uh maybe they're pulling
from below somehow okay
like here
is that's what's happening
which one is true
or and i mean he's got maybe a different
explanation i can only simulate
uh you know with his green pixies uh how
i think that he might be trying to
simulate gravity but you know i don't
mind he can he can come up with a
different scenario and tell me no it's
neither push nor pull you know okay
you tell me i don't know how you do with
your green pixies and i'm granting the
green pixies
okay now if green pixies mean something
else that i don't know about and you
have a different mechanism then i'll
swallow my beer
okay
okay so here we have again the spoon in
free fall okay this is what we see
and and you say well bill how do you do
it you're so smart right okay smarty pan
let's see how you do it okay this is how
we do it we say that every atom of that
spoon is bound physically bound by
electromagnetic ropes very thin thinner
than uh the planck constant or is it
thinner than anything you can imagine
we're talking about every atom of that
spoon being connected to every atom of
the earth
and here we see the mechanism
this is why a spoon falls to the ground
because every atom of that spoon is
bound to every atom on earth and no i
did not draw every rope okay
it's just conceptual so that you can
understand the mechanism if the spoon is
made of gazillions of atoms and each one
of those is connected to the gazillion
gazillion gazillion atoms of the earth
you can see why as it falls the ropes
fan out
that's the mechanism mechanism of
gravity that none of these idiots from
cambridge from harvard from oxford and
from caltech none of these idiots these
mathematicians ever figured out
it was so simple all you had to do was
make the invisible objects that connect
every atom to the earth visible once you
make it visible the mechanism is kid
stuff it's for babies
okay
so let's make sure we understand why all
these mathematicians were never doing
science because to do science in in the
context of physics right you have to
make the invisible objects that mother
nature uses visible if you don't make
them visible you're doing magic
okay that's what it is these people
instead put concepts in there they said
we're gonna do it with mass we're gonna
do it with field we're gonna do it with
energy
what is that
there's not can you draw a picture of
energy please illustrate it for me show
me what energy is
and then then you can talk okay
but here we have uh and you say bill
where did you get this nonsense of the
ropes you know my rope
where did you get this nonsense that all
atoms are interconnected and that there
are invisible intangible ropes
well the first thing you have to
understand is that
um
an object is not that which you can see
or touch which is the definition
everybody has out there
existence exists
is not that which you can see or touch
which is the definition of exist that
most people have out there
and that's the one the mathematicians
cambridge and harvard that's the one
they use they use the seed touch
and so they say let's go to the lab
what are you going to go for to the lab
for well i want to i want to find out
what gravity is
how are you going to find out in the lab
with an experiment
you deranged [ __ ] how are you going to
find out going to the lab when you can't
see or touch that which is invisible and
intangible
what part don't you understand
mother nature has invisible intangible
objects
there because the word object is not
defined as that which you can see or
touch the word object is defined as that
which has shape this has shape a rope
the electromagnetic rope you cannot see
or touch so please don't go to the lab
don't waste your time don't waste your
brain your tiny brain
if if you go to the lab you're never
going to figure out you have to sit back
visualize how mother nature could be
doing gravity
and you say well where did you get this
grove this that all atoms are
interconnected
okay so let's for those who require
proof and evidence because they think
science is about proof and evidence
and testing the hypothesis whatever that
nonsense is okay let's test the
hypothesis okay let's let's present
proof and evidence for all the those
deranged
individuals who went to college and and
just uh parented the party line okay
here's uh a professor
phd in physics mathematics okay he's
gonna tell you where i got that from
here it is okay his name is uh richard
muller he's from berkeley university
listen carefully okay instead of opening
your mouth okay here it goes give me a
second here it goes
what's the force of gravity on me
it's the pull of the earth
on my body
so for example if you have the earth
with its big mass here and you have you
with your little mass here
that every atom on the
earth is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
on the other hand a lot of atoms here
you're pulling on you're pulling on all
of them amazing thing about gravity is
it goes right through things
okay
you're pulling on every atom of the
earth
do that with space-time
how are you going to do with space-time
with warped time how are you going to
pull on an atom
you know on earth
every atom in your body is pulling on
every atom on earth every atom on earth
is pulling on you how do you pull if not
with an elongated object
if every atom on earth is bound to every
atom
in your body
then you can see why when you jump you
fall back
because now you have a physical
mechanism
but to say that you did it because of
gravity or which is what you're trying
to explain really or that you did it
because
mass or or because of you know energy or
force or field what are you saying
what's the mechanism so i i consider
your stupid field your stupid energy
what how do you explain the mechanism
i want to see i want to see the
mechanism that you propose for why grab
why this spoon falls to the floor
that's the issue and if you cannot
explain it you're not a physicist you're
a damn mathemagician that's all you are
who's opposing
using the word physics to label yourself
we don't have physicists on earth on any
university on the planet
this is the only site that does physic
we do it with objects we explain gravity
with objects we explain magnetism with
objects we explain electricity with
objects and obviously the working of the
atom okay so here it is one more uh time
okay just so you can see it so for
examples here if you have the earth
there's a big mass here and you have you
with your little mass here every atom on
earth is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
are you listening or is it going through
your from one ear to the other with
nothing in between
the amazing thing about gravity is that
it goes right through things
how does gravity go right through things
unless every atom is connected to all
other atoms physically
that's the only way you can explain this
and the reason no one can explain why
two objects a spoon and the earth
you know in ten thousand years no one
has been able to explain gravity is
because they don't use objects they
don't use things
and if you're going to explain a
mexicanism you need things you need to
make the invisible things that are here
which are untouchable and unseeable
you have to make those things visible
then someone can explain the mechanism
imagine uh if you're pulling on a rope
that's wound around a pulley
and holding a box
okay so you pull on the rope and the box
goes up
now let's get rid of the rope let's make
it an invisible rope
so the guy goes like this
and the box goes up
and you don't see the mechanism you say
how did the box go up every time he goes
like this the box goes up
and such a simple thing all you have to
do is make the rope visible and then
it's kid stuff
but as long as you don't see the rope
and you can't touch the rope
people say oh it's magic
okay and that's the only difference the
only difference between
what the mathematicians do and what we
do here is that we make the objects
visible that mother nature uses father
universe whoever you believe in
okay
anyways uh that's the
the next installment on that one uh i'll
continue with this fellow further on
we've got a lot to talk about uh of all
the issues that he raised okay let's
move on to the subject matter of today
and that's going to be this thing we
call space actually not space it's a
portion of space which they call place
more known as
void i call it position
which is what the mathematicians used to
call it now they uh they don't use that
word position anymore but they're all
the same they're all synonyms why was
this important because the greeks
started out on the wrong foot obviously
they were so backward you know they
could just barely think and they were
the first people to try to think these
out these things out okay
so they made a lot of errors okay we can
excuse them for that okay but none of
them plato aristotle socrates
um
you know all of these folks out there
democritus none of them figured it out
none of them figured any of this out all
they could do is what is try to
imagine how all this could work and they
they got it everything wrong and they
got it all wrong because they could not
see the invisible intangible
mediators that mother nature uses that
was the whole problem and that's still
the whole problem today nothing has
changed in 2500 years
okay so the first thing we have to do is
look at the
words that mathematics uses which they
never defined
and which are absolutely essential to do
physics you cannot do physics unless you
lay this foundation which is the
foundations of the proper language to do
physics okay and so here it is these are
words that the math and magicians never
define that's a mathematician down here
at the bottom by the way
fundamental concepts that have stumped
and baffled the mathematicians
throughout the ages
space no one can have no one has any
idea what space is they don't know how
to define it they don't know what it is
they have opinions
and they don't have a a proper uh
notion of what space is
but the one we're going to talk about
today is position
uh the um
greeks called it place or at least it
was translated this place so
we got to go with that word
god position
uh point nobody knows what a point is
you make a dot on the board
or with your chalk
with your chuck or with a crayon you do
it on on a piece of paper
and you say that's a point
well i'm staring at a dot
that's that's a dot
yeah but you should not confuse the dot
with a point
oh okay so what's the point that's
what's objectively in front of me
so what's this point thingy
it's a location
so what was the purpose of the dot
what was to give a pictorial
representation of a location
so we we have irrationality because
they're using the heart to represent
love
and they're saying we're going to be
moving love
what do you mean you're going to be
moving love
you can move the heart but but if you're
going to talk about love get rid of the
heart and let's talk about love
and it's the same thing they put a point
meaning a dot that's what they draw
that's what's objectively in front of
your eyes but then they say well we have
so many locations then they deal with
the concept location forget about the
dot altogether
and so this is this is why they can't
define the word point today because they
took an object they mixed it with a
concept and they said it's a point it's
a dot location
location dot dot location location not
it's a point that's what a point is at
that location
okay that's the problem it's a heart
love that's what it that's what a point
is it's very easy to define a point you
either you either have the object known
as dot or you have the concept known as
location and if you're going to use
location it's it's a concept and you
should use the concept why why use this
new word called point use the word
location if that's what you're going to
talk about very simple okay it's the
language that confused and drives all
these mathematicians out you know nuts
okay we have location same thing nobody
defined that distance nobody knows what
a distance is everybody confuses
distance with distance traveled with
displacement and with length
they say what is the distance this is
the length of blah blah blah blah blah
what is the length it's the distance of
blah blah blah blah blah
and they're not talking about neither
distance or or or length they're talking
about distance traveled what they're
doing is unrolling the measuring tape
and they take the tip
of the measuring tape
and they
they say okay it's so many
uh meters how many feet or whatever
somebody miles from the tip
of the measuring tape to where i started
so they count what i mean what is a
mathematician interested in he's only
interested in numbers and units and
quantities he's not interested in the
physical aspect and so that's the
problem you know distance
is separation we don't need any numbers
to talk about distance not in physics
okay distance traveled well you could
have
a qualitative also distance travel you
say okay there's so much separation
after you unroll the tape you don't need
to have units there either it's this
placement that's when you start putting
numbers in there okay that's when they
said we need to put numbers and units in
there okay
and of course they confuse it with the
line because
they they draw a little stick
and they say that's a line
it's one dimensional
which i forgot to mention the point is
also zero dimensional they say
actually it's non-dimensional because
it's a concept but here with the line
the same thing they say it's one
dimensional it's made out of zero
dimensional points
what what do you mean
what are you talking about
they're not talking about lines they're
not talking about points what they're
talking about is an itinerary a
trajectory and they call that a line
why because they replaced it with a
stick
okay and they call that stick a line
what is a line it has both worlds it has
the object the stick
and it has the concept which is the
itinerary
motion
a series of locations
points
and so this is the problem there the
they're talking about
they're talking about motion and they
put a stick
now what sense does that make to
represent motion with a stick
okay so and and then they get confused
because they don't know if they're
you're talking about the stick or the
itinerary okay and they call it a line
okay anyways uh dimension same thing
nonsense they don't know what a
dimension is a dimension they say is a
bunch of coordinates
the
number of coordinates no that's not what
a dimension is dimension is three
mutually perpendicular lines that's the
three dimension
uh the definition of three dimension and
each one of those is known as a
dimension and the dimensions are length
and height very simple baby stuff for
kindergarteners physics is for babies
anyone can understand physics you don't
need to go to college you don't need to
go to high school to understand physics
physics is intuitive it's how mother
nature runs her shop how father universe
runs the universe that's what it's all
about
and they never define the two important
words which is the word object in the
word exist
physics cannot be done without objects
if you remove all the objects from the
universe your god comes in and removes
everything
you got nothing okay great now you have
nothing what's going on what's happening
you need object you need things so you
need to define the word object first
word that you need to define in physics
without the word object you can't be
doing physics
and then exist uh physics only deals
with those objects that exist
okay so um you need to define those two
words object didn't exist why do the
idiots who call themselves atheists the
idiots who call themselves theists the
idiots who call themselves agnostics why
do these three idiots these three
stooges go around in circles
well they go around in circles because
they never define the word exist
that's why they go around in circles
that's why i put
religious people
like theis
together with atheists together with
agnostic they all should be executed
every single one of them that means 99
plus of humanity because they don't even
know what they're talking about you have
to define the word exist if you're going
to talk about god
very simple if you don't know what the
word exists means then
one guy says well i believe god exists
the other guy said oh no i know god
doesn't exist
and the other guy said well i don't know
if he exists or not i don't know what
test i can run maybe i should run an
experiment to prove the existence of god
no
kill them all all three of the all three
stooges just kill them all get rid of
all of them okay and obviously they
never define the word concept okay and
so you need to know the difference
between an object and a concept
and people don't understand they think
field is a physical object they think
energy is a physical object absolutely
not those are concepts there's no
physical object in physics called energy
nothing called uh field
no physical object feel and it takes 10
years for an uh mathematician to
understand what i just said
to understand the difference between an
object and a concept and of course no
one that did that in the last 10 000
years
okay so um
how did the greek start well they
thought uh there was this ether
between the moon and the earth okay all
that black stuff out there they said
it's ether
it was like an air of the gods okay and
so this is more or less the notion that
they had you had the earth air
surrounded by water surrounded by air
surrounded by fire and then the ether
came
and in the middle ages they had that uh
notion there where they have the guy
sticking his neck out i guess um to
space
between the earth and the moon and that
was the ether in there all we needed to
do is color code in we we would
okay so here we have it
we have uh we start with the ether but
you would say you would think that the
greeks would have said okay what's out
there
you know what is that black stuff
and they said it's ether okay but what
is the ether what are we talking about
and so they they imagined it as air
because that's essentially what the word
ether means it's a sort of godly air and
what's the air bunch of particles so
they were thinking of a bunch of
particles the black stuff is also a
bunch of particles much like air but
it's a different type of air so one the
gods breathe zeus you know
okay
so that was a starting point but they
had different schools to analyze this
word void this word place they called it
place i guess they called it place
because that's how it's translated okay
maybe they meant something else but i
think more or less they were talking
about the same thing void
place position
all those were cinnamon they were
talking about that you're gonna see that
in what in how they defended their
arguments okay
so um
these were the different greek schools
okay
uh i'm not gonna go through all of them
but here you can see you know the main
ones and where more or less these folks
were located this was the greek
uh
[Music]
world okay
and you have different schools in
different places okay we're going to
look at some of these fellows okay we're
going to find out what they
what the schools or what each individual
thought about or how how they thought
especially about void
space
nothingness
was there a nothingness does nothingness
exist you know is it a physical object
is it nothing and if so what is nothing
so you need to define these terms to be
able to talk rationally and the big
problem we have is no one ever defined
it nobody ever figured out what space is
to this day okay as we're going to see
here
okay so here we have a good old airy
okay
and what did he say okay so he starts
trying to figure out the void okay so he
says the physicist must have a knowledge
of place
he needs to know what place means you
know the site occupied by an object the
volume
whichever way you want to see it the
volume of space
but it's like you take a chunk of space
out of space you say that chunk we're
going to call that place
white place because it's the site
occupied by an object okay that was the
notion
as well as the infinite
again mathematicians
namely whether there is such a thing
thing
or not any in the manner of its
existence they were talking about is it
a thing and if it is a thing does it
exist did they define what a thing is
did they
define what exists means absolutely not
and those were the two key words okay
and what it is both because and i like
this because this is this is just geno
okay it says
uh things which exist are somewhere
arie said that
350 what uh yeah 350 bc
things that exist are somewhere
that is the definition of exist
more or less and no one has ever
discovered it no one ever used it arie
doesn't even know what he said
he has no idea what he just said there
he said something tremendously important
things
which exist are somewhere
and non-existent is nowhere
an object that exists is an object that
has location
that's the definition of exist now we
can use that word
consistently in an argument in a debate
in a dissertation whatever
now you can talk about god does god
exist well let's look at the definition
what is the definition object that has
location
first the first step is got an object
is it is got a thing or is it a concept
if god is a concept like love
intelligence
you know grace
then god cannot exist by definition the
definition requires that it's an object
if it wants to exist
you know the table i have in my head
dreaming thinking of
that one doesn't exist because it
doesn't have location
this table does exist because it has
location well there's there's distance
between the table and my chest
between the table and the walls
so there's distance
the set of distances location now we
have an object that has location we can
say that by definition pursuant to the
definition the table exists we have to
do the same thing with god does god
exist
he's got an object or a concept well
he's made in our image so i guess he's
an object yeah then all he's got to do
now is have location he's got to have
distance between god and me
god can hide in the tenth dimension if
he wants but there better be a line of
direction from him directly to me
i don't care where he hides in the
universe or outside the universe there's
got to be a straight line of direction
from me to him
period we're done
and otherwise he doesn't exist because
that's what the word exists means that's
how it's defined scientifically okay
and so yeah
you know if god is a concept he can't
exist the space time exists
space and time are concepts space is a
synonym of nothing and time is a concept
obviously i'm not going to go into
details there but space-time is a
concept so it doesn't exist by
definition so we can't talk about you
can't use it in in science to say that
this in existence space-time is what
prevents the earth from flying out of
the solar system only idiots use that
kind of language
okay the question what is place
presents many difficulties yeah no kid
but i like what he said tonight he said
moreover we have inherited nothing from
previous thinkers
he was criticized remember he's talking
350 years before christ so he's talking
about the guys that came before him
plato socrates pythagoras he you know
he's got all these guys behind him and
he says none of them gave us any idea
none of them
none of these so-called thinkers okay um
you know he inherited nothing from them
so he's accusing them and so here we
have the first one he goes uh again i'm
not going to go through all the schools
uh here we go to annex aggress okay and
so he analyzes what annex zagara said
and so he says the following he says
anxious does not disprove
uh what people really mean by void
does not exist but only their erroneous
way of speaking
in other words he was saying it was a
semantical issue okay
that uh
he was just criticizing the way they
were
phrasing the existence of the void okay
and he says merely gives uh
an ingenious demonstration that air is
something showing the resistance of the
air so if you move your hand and you
feel the air okay you feel resistance
there you feel something there you're
touching something that you can't see by
the way again object is not that which
you can see or touch you can't see the
air but
hopefully there is an object a thing
okay anything made out of atoms had
better be a thing okay
and uh so it says void does not exist
but
he shows it through the air through the
fact that you know there's air wherever
you think there is void that was
essentially annex agarose way of
thinking but people really mean that
there is an empty interval in which
there is no no sensible body in other
words what aristotle was saying was
saying that alexandra's uh reasoning is
wrong it's irrational he's saying
alexander says look there's air so there
can't be void
because there's air where you think
there is nothing
and he says that's wrong because that
only proves the existence of air it
doesn't prove the exis the non-existence
of void okay of nothing okay he says uh
you have to show that there is an
interval where there is no matter
including air
that's what uh uh arie is trying to
you know that's where he's criticizing
about anxious it is not then the
existence of air that needs to be proved
again mathematicians always talk about
proof they prove everything then they
don't know anything but the
non-existence of an interval okay
different from uh the bodies in other
words you have a body and you have to
show that between two bodies there's
absolutely nothing so he's gonna try to
prove this okay and again it's important
to know that all these people were
trying to figure out in a way space what
is space
you know is is there something that
black stuff out there
and they all started looking at position
at what happens when you move something
out of position and they say what is
there something that occupies that same
position once you pull that thing out if
you pull the chair out what what fills
the void
and you know sagaris would say air fills
it okay that's that that was his answer
and uh aristotle says
yeah but uh you got to do it without air
you got to show that when you pull the
chair out nothing absolutely nothing
remains behind so you have this volume
of chair
left behind that nothing fills it that
sort of thing that's that's the what he
was getting to okay
okay so here we have the iliatics okay
and uh with these people primarily was
uh he analyzes melissa's but the first
guy was probably zeno there and
parmenides you know one of those two was
the first one they're not sure because
they don't have the exact dates
but as far as i know xeno was really the
first guy to create this iliadic school
again
you know these schools were spread
around in the greek empire
and what do they believe in or what was
their argument says all is immovable
they didn't believe in motion
what do you mean you don't believe in
motion how can that possibly be of
course there's motion look i'm moving my
hand
and they say no
there is no motion you should how can
how can they conclude such a
irrationality
and these these folks had this idea that
if
if you move your hand and you leave a
void behind
then the void exists
there is a thing called void that has
shape
that's where your hand was
and they said that can't be there's no
such thing as a void of hand or
you know
a void that's shaped like your hand a
volume that's left behind there's no
such thing
and so there is no motion because you
can only move to where there's void
okay
but
all boys are filled
that was more or less their argument
they said there is no change
yeah just like you're listening that
that's that's how these people concluded
you know they're famous for that
okay so uh what the uh
the atomos
uh primarily democratist and i guess it
was his teacher lucifus okay and they
were from uh up north in thrace okay
right north of um of greece okay
and uh so they they uh brushed aside all
these iliads they say they're all crazy
okay and what was their argument they
said democracies and lucifers
hold that there is an interval which
divides the whole body so as to break
its continuity
okay so that you have
uh you know if you move something like
you separate an apple okay you separate
an apple
and
these folks said when you separate the
the two halves
you're leaving a void behind there has
to be a void behind
and the other fellows say no you can't
because one guy said you're moving it
into a void and there is no such thing
as void that's the first one and the
other guy said
as soon as you separate them air fills
the void
instantaneously
so you you never have void you never
have separation but these guys are
criticizing iliadi saying you're crazy
what do you mean there's no emotion of
course there's motion and we're not even
going to talk to you anymore
so uh they uh blocked them
uh that's how they agree she they
invented blocking okay
okay so uh what does uh he say about
pythagoras another school okay eric says
pythagoras held that void exists
void exist that they define exist now
did they define what an object is no
it exists can only be an object that has
location uh you heard areas say
something similar okay and so these guys
are saying uh the void exists that means
he's saying that a void is an object
okay
and that it centers it enters the heaven
itself
which is it which as it were inhales it
from the infinite air okay so oh the
gods they uh they breathe all this good
stuff
that's when they invented drugs i think
[Laughter]
okay here we have another uh
analysis he
analyzes his boss his previous teacher
plato okay he did go to the academy
plato is the uh in in the timaeus says
that matter and space are the same
matter and space
things and nothings are the same
that's what plato said okay
for the participant meaning space uh the
the thing okay and space are
identical
so he's saying that when you remove
the
the ball right you leave a hole behind
in space
he's saying the the hole that he left
behind and the ball they're the same
thing
meaning the volumes are the same thing
meaning in mathematics in the religion
of mathematics it's the same thing
a ball is the same thing as the sphere
as the
volume because they're looking at
numbers they're not looking at
qualitative
whether a ball is the same thing as a
you know volume
uh in in the middle of space if you can
imagine that
this is the issue so this is where you
get mathematics involved with uh with
science okay unfortunately you know it
really got
introduced through geometry that's where
mathematics began that's when they
started using these concepts such as
location
and
itinerary and confusing it with line and
point meaning you know stick
and dot
that's that's where the problem began
with mathematics geometry is the first
uh irrationality in mathematics okay
completely irrational all the
definitions are irrational
okay so um
so here we have
aries reasoning for place for this void
and again they're not looking at space
like what is space this infinite space
that's out there they weren't looking at
that they said well between the moon and
the
earth there's this ether and that was a
space but we don't touch that what they
were looking at is location
within here on earth in other words they
were looking at void they were looking
at position but the volume occupied by
an object that's what they were
analyzing
and from there a lot of people
extrapolated oh this is the notion they
had of space
okay so
keep in mind they're talking about a
chunk of space and not this
gigantic space that you know supposedly
where matter flows out there in in space
okay so he says the following says what
then after all this place
place meaning void meaning
volume etc
places that is what contains that of
which it is the place
okay
uh
places where
an object doctor buys place and and
that's uh and whatever the object
occupies we'll call that place okay
great place is no part of the thing okay
so he's saying at least he's saying
place and thing are two separate things
okay
uh the immediate place of a thing is
neither
less nor greater than the thing okay
they have the same volume plays can be
left behind by the thing and be
separable
[Laughter]
he's saying that you know you move the
ball and you leave place behind okay
that's that was his notion again we're
talking about this position that the
object occupied okay this place this
void
uh all place admits of the dis
tinction of up and down and each of the
bodies is naturally carried to its
appropriate place and rest there okay
and this makes the place either up or
down okay so these are the notions that
he's going to start with he's going to
start his reasoning what does he uh good
old arie conclude with
and again it shows that mathematicians
are not uh called out to ever do physics
okay they have no notion of physics
and this is where it started where
everybody
took off from there the existence of
place existence of place he just told me
that it's got to be a thing he's saying
well place is a thing okay so i guess
that's where his contradiction comes in
he's saying place is a thing and he's
talking about the existence of place is
held to be obvious it's obvious
place exists we don't need the ball we
have place there the ball where the ball
used to be
from the fact of mutual replacement
fact that you can replace
one thing with another okay saying the
place is there the place exists the void
exists
what now contains air
right you took the ball out it was
filled with air
contained water
so that or no water in this case so that
clearly the place or space into which
and out of which they pass with
something different from both
so you pull the water out air fills it
but water is not the same thing as
place air is not the same thing as place
so there's this third entity called
place which is separate or distinct from
air and water
that's how good that's how we started
our culture
our mathematics
the religion of mathematics
okay irrationality 150 irrationality
anything coming out of cambridge out of
harvard out of caltech mit oxford st
andrews all of them all they have is
irrationality from china all the way to
the united states from russia all the
way to south america from europe all the
way to africa all the same
and all phds coming out of the
university they just babble nonsense
irrationalities one right after another
okay so let's keep going here
uh what happens next well we have to
wait a few years after that a few
hundred years right we get to newton i
covered that the other day so i'll go
quickly here uh he the only thing i want
to mention here is newton
uh separated place from position and he
says it at the bottom positions property
have no quantity
so he's saying that position is a
qualitative notion it's again it's like
the volume occupied by an object whereas
he's saying that place
um i guess is associated with numbers
again you know this distinction that
only mathematicians
notice because in physics we don't care
about any of that okay
it's nonsense poppycock okay
okay so here we have um
guys who came a little later than i know
first we have a fight between newton and
leibniz and they have two different
notions of what space is out there we're
talking about this so-called absolute
space
whether you can gauge your position with
respect to this immovable
space
can you use it as a reference is there a
border to space
does space have a surface
you know like if it were a sphere
does it have a surface like that in that
sense
and these two had two different ideas
and remember they fought over the
calculus here they're gonna fight all
also over what space is and here's the
two verses here you have liveness and he
says space doesn't exist independently
of things if god destroyed all matter
space would cease to exist
in other words he's saying that you need
things to conceptualize space
what does newton say he says space is an
immense container he sees it as a
container he's uh talking about absolute
space here you know this big space in
which
all uh galaxies stars planets etc are in
right
objects gauge their movements with
respect to it and if god destroyed all
matter space would still continue to
exist
okay so again these people never define
what an object is they never define the
word exist and so they talk they're
talking about the existence of a concept
uh the universe or or space
neither universe nor space exists
because universe is a concept and we'll
see in a minute and uh and space is a
concept space is a synonym of nothing
and nothing is what that which has no
shape
and we'll get to that in a second as
well okay but here let's continue here
we have uh
two guys that came right after that a
short while after that not quite a
hundred years but we have david hume
and emmanuel kent and
hume says upon he says space does not
exist independently of objects again you
know we hear that over and over can't be
conceived in the absence of objects what
is what is he doing he's introducing the
observer
he he's saying that space has something
to do with the observer
space can't be separated from sensations
and touch for example right and objects
separated by distance are equal or the
same as objects separated by invisible
intangible objects
talking about the rope i guess that okay
no it's not the same thing if they're
separated by distance they're separated
by nothing meaning by space and if
they're separated by invisible
intangible objects such as the rope then
they are separated by an object so uh
david hume could see the objects and
that's why he had to
reach such an irrational conclusion
space is not infinitely divisible
okay
and then kant says something different
he says can't
can't imagine okay the absence of space
okay uh he can imagine the absence of
objects but he cannot imagine the
absence of space but he he's wrong
because see you can imagine the absence
of space let's assume god came in with
his magic wand in erased space somehow
removes space we don't care how he does
a magic trick he removes space well then
you would have an infinite block of
matter
that's what you would have so yes you
can imagine the absence of space it
would be a single block of matter
an infinite block of matter which would
be a contradiction with the definition
of the word object which is that which
has shape and an infinite whatever does
not have shape
okay so he says infinite space newt's
absolute space that's what he was
referring to right when he talks about
infinite space is no more than an
abstraction not worth losing any sleep
over just the concept humans invented to
make sense of the separation
um
for example you know the earth and the
moon
so
so this is uh these are the conclusions
these folks reach in great measure
because they never define the word
object the word exist
and of course the word space because if
you are going to talk about space or
void or position or any or volume first
thing you should do is define the term
so that you know what you're talking
about but these people use a
irrational um what are they
called um
these definitions that um they they
develop through the theory okay through
that they tell it to you at the end of
the theory okay
um
and so yeah you can't use those uh
definitions can't remember the the name
of it right now
okay so uh
here we go uh with what space is today
what these people think of space today
and this fellow who criticized me uh
he essentially goes with this with these
notions of space time etc and these are
statements that i
got out there and you'll
can search from you know
from people who state and make them and
they're usually
phds you know so you're not talking
about just an ordinary
joe out there in the streets space-time
is one big container and all of us move
around in it
yeah is is space-time a container is
that what space is is that what time is
a container and we move around in it
meaning we engage our position our
location with respect to the edges of
space-time because it's a big container
and obviously they'll never tell you
what's outside of it because that's
where the intelligence stops
and then the nexus of space and time are
effectively interchangeable and
fundamentally the same thing
so they say time and space are the same
thing yeah and he's not whoever said
that was not the first one to say it uh
you'll look at uh stephen hawking he
says the same nonsense
why posit a giant entity that acts like
a container if we don't have to
and yeah you'll hear the statement empty
space
and it's like saying empty empty like
humpty dumpty you know empty empty
that's what you're saying or space space
or nothing nothing
space is empty it's nothing so to say
empty space what are you talking about
you know space is empty
and
and so they stop using the word place
but
you know it's essentially the notion of
void of empty
but these notions both void and empty
means that there is no object there okay
and again that's that's not what space
is space is not the absence of objects
you don't you do not define space by
saying no object no nothing no no thing
there that's not the definition of space
because then what is an object well it's
the no space there
you just go back and forth you know you
can go around in circles never define
words
with their negative you know a cat is
not
you don't define a cat as not a dog
and you don't define a dog as not a cat
no those are not definitions of dog and
cat okay
and here you have
what they use today the notion of
position it's no longer the position in
the sense the volume occupied by an
object what it
has been relegated to essentially is the
location of
an object uh with respect to a center in
other words position really is a uh
distance traveled it's motion there's no
difference between position and motion
in the religion of mathematics okay a
euclidean vector what is a vector
um
magnitude and direction so they're
talking about
motion right that represents the
position i like that the position is the
position great of a point p in space in
relation to an arbitrary reference
origin oh okay in other words they're
talking about what a um
ordered pair an ordered pair that's what
they're talking about in other words it
is the displacement what what is
position displacement or translation
what is position translation movement
there's no difference between position
and motion that maps the origin to p
okay
so yeah this is the notion that they
ended up with they ended up with this
nonsense because in the religion of
mathematics they don't care about
qualitative stuff so so for them
position and motion our synonym
displacement is the same thing distance
is the same thing as distance traveled
as length they're all the same why
because they're going to unroll the
measuring tape the they're going to look
at the tip of the measuring tape how
much it moved from beginning to end and
they're going to put a number
and followed by a unit a quantity that's
that's what all these things are they're
all the same because that's what they
can put in an equation
it's got nothing to do with reality with
with the world of physics which is
qualitatively exclusively
qualitative
and these people are
are looking for you know to putting
stuff in their equations for that they
have to measure they have to observe go
to the lab
and so
while they're there they say well let's
see if we can find out what gravity is
yeah unseeable and untouchable mediators
of gravity they're going to discover it
in the lab sure
have i'll give you the rest of the year
to do it i'll give you 100 years 400
years
okay and today we have a um
what is it um we have a void
in space
we have a little void in space and it's
known as a black hole it looks like this
okay
and yeah you can have that little hole
in space
and they call that a black hole
and it doesn't look very black because
what's black is on the outside is space
is what looks black dark or whatever but
they call that a black hole and what is
a black hole a singularity it's a little
hole that they drilled through space
which is nothing so they're doing a hole
through nothing okay which is that which
has no shape and um and they build these
wormholes that go to other universes
which i don't know what they're
separated from our universe with i mean
what separates our universe from theirs
if our universe contains space time and
matter as they say
and their universe contains space time
and matter
what is the
wormhole through what is this little
hole the entrance to
and what is the
outlet
through you know what is this uh
wormhole which is like a tunnel what is
that true what's the medium it's true
i mean i can ask bugs bunny there you
know uh uh
where where's this hole he can say it's
in the earth
so the hole is a concept really right
but it's a it's an opening in the earth
we call that a hole
well what's the black hole uh what's the
what's it into space nothing that which
has no shape
and it goes
you come out of another universe out of
another black hole over there i guess a
white hole maybe you know so we have
this little tunnel through
what
through space through nothing great
right this up okay so here are the
conclusions okay for today
position place it's the object itself
that's what it is in science so we don't
use the words position place
uh the volume we don't care about any of
those because all those are the object
itself
that's it period we're done okay and
that's what all these people uh the
greeks especially you know they've been
running around in circles talking about
whether you if you move the ball out of
the
space
is there something filling in is there
was there a hole there to begin with
that it occupied to begin with you know
and does it exist you know so they went
around in circles because they never
defined the terms all they had to do is
define position as the object itself and
we don't need the word position at all
or place or void we don't need any of
those words at all
uh what is void void is same thing is
empty when you say void you mean that
you subtracted something from it empty
means also that you took something out
that's the notion that the word empty
and void mean absence of something
that's not equal to space that's not the
definition of space okay
object is the thing
what is it that which has shape
what is space
nothing
the opposite
no thing nothing that which has no shape
now we can use these words consistently
in a dissertation we have
something and we have nothing what is
something that which has shape what is
nothing that which doesn't have shape
we're done very simple baby stuff you
don't even need to go to high school to
learn this stuff
uh 10 year old can learn this
space is uh the antonyma of an object
they're antonyms okay opposites
matter objects that exist
so if you take the collection of objects
in the universe that ex or within a
system the subsystem you can take also
as well but matter refers to all objects
that exist
uh what is an object that exists an
object that has location
okay so if the object has location
set of distances to all other objects
then it has uh then it exists by
definition not because you believe not
because you know not because you can
prove or run an experiment because it
meets the definition period we're done
it's pursuant to the definition you
don't believe in chairs
you don't believe in uh
balls or in uh trees
and you should not believe in god
and you should not know god
or or disbelieve in god or disbelieve in
chair or disbelieve in tree
okay you define the word exist and you
say
what is exist
it's a thing
yeah that which i shape that has
location the set of distances does the
tree meet the definition the tree exists
by definition whether i believe or not
does god exist well he's got a physical
object yes god is a physical object okay
then he can exist he he can exist he may
exist he's allowed to exist he still
needs to meet the second condition which
is
is there separation between him and me
does he have location
if god doesn't have location he doesn't
exist and if he's a concept he doesn't
even qualify for the first part
universe is a concept no such physical
object called universe people say oh the
universe is infinite no no such monster
as infinite objects first of all but
universe is not an object universe is a
concept why because it has two
uh things or things treated as a thing's
momentarily space here is treated as a
thing we're saying two things we're
comparing two things we're saying matter
and space we're saying space is not like
matter matter is not like space so we
have two things and therefore it's a
concept what is a concept it's a word
that invokes two objects
all concepts invoke two objects it's a
relation between two objects that's what
a concept is universe is a relation
between matter and space therefore
universe is a concept
universe cannot be said to exist because
it's not an object only objects may be
said to exist pursuant to the definition
we're done
okay
okay
let's move on to
some of the
questions that people made since last
time let's find out what these fine
folks have to say
one fellow the only thought who dealt
with the issue of extinction to some
degree and
it's the only one that i'm going to
mention for extension says the more
wealth the more wealthy a nation becomes
the less children the people have
the higher individuals are taxed the
less they have children
in typical uh of western thinking your
linear progression to zero population
completely dismisses the cycle of
population
which goes up and down up and down in an
overall uptrend upward trend okay
um
this follows got it all wrong
he's got each one of those points is
wrong
okay
they're not irrational he's just uh
ignorant of the of the facts okay of
what's really going on
and uh these notions you know again a
lot of people share them i would say the
majority of humanity shares them okay so
let's find out what's wrong with them
okay
here's a
19th century
it was the rich
that had children
it wasn't the poor
see people say oh the poor people have
children which already denies the second
point which is higher individuals are
taxed the less they have children well
obviously a poor person
you know today right
has very little money if because he's
being taxed
how come they say that it's the poor
that have children the rich don't
which was the opposite of the 19th
century and here it is these were the
families of the 19th century they were
well-to-do families and they had lots of
children
and there on the bottom right in
yellowish color
that's a father known as israel and he
had 12 boys and one girl at least 13
children at least as far as we know
and he was he was a rich guy he had lots
of land he had cattle or uh whatever you
know sheep
and so you know they they needed to
create empires and so they had lots of
children
and so the rich did have children
throughout history okay they wanted to
what was god saying he's saying
spread like the sands of the desert
you know if you could do that you were
macho man you know alpha
guy okay uh but here is uh another issue
that he raised and that's this and
that's that um
the reason we're not having children is
everybody's moving to the cities and you
can see that this is the
uh known as transition from the rural
areas to the urban areas and the red
line there is the world
all the others are
separate countries you can see they're
all going up it's universal every every
country on the planet has this
has this trend
so
what's happening is people are all
moving to the cities
and when you move to the cities you
can't have children it's forbidden by
law
i like to say it's forbidden by law to
have children in the cities you can't
have children if you have child we'll
kill them
just that simple you can't have 10
children in an apartment like
israel had 12 children in the country i
hope you understand that
and then yeah tax is one issue probably
not the most important reason but then
you have culture
and then you have room you have to have
also
you have children they're already an
anchor you can't go on vacation because
now you got to take this little puppy
that you had
okay and so there are many reasons for
why
uh couples don't have children and you
know the young couples today female and
male both they just they they get
together first of all they don't form
permanent unions
there's a lot of divorces out there so
since there's nothing permanent why have
a child it just complicates things you
know in four years down the road you get
a divorce what do you do with the kid
the money you can fight over but the kid
when you do a solomonic
trial you
cut them in half
one pulls on one arm the other on the
other so yeah
the fact that we're moving to the cities
is the killer of birth rates and here's
the trend and again it's it's not like
they go up and down like he says not
true at all that was the past that was
history
we're past history okay here it is since
1963 the train has steadily
steadily
steadily gone down
okay the trend has always gone down and
will continue to go down now there's no
chance whatsoever that humans can
rebound and get that trend to go up ever
again it's impossible it's against the
law of mother nature okay so you cannot
have that trend go up why because we
moved to the cities when you move to the
cities you don't have children and you
cannot force people for cultural
economic et cetera et cetera reasons to
uh have children and get that trend to
go back up again no we're not going to
have more children anymore okay from now
on it's just going to be fewer and fewer
children on the planet okay nothing we
can do about it with all our
intelligence aside from the fact that
there's many people out there who say oh
the world is overpopulated we don't need
more children there's a lot of people
like that as well they don't want
children but if you ask the pope you
know my good friend frankie uh he would
say yeah go ahead and have children but
nobody's having them
yeah right now you know we're not going
to have more children
it's out of the question uh
pretty soon having a child will be as uh
uh frequent as haley's comment
what is it 75 76 years
okay
now uh
one file here asks
a big question
let's see what he's got to say okay he
says
here's a big question
what causes the motion the action of
these models
he's talking about
original motion the cause of
first cause i guess first cause of
motion
without the great why answered god can
always be provided as the prime mover
are these guys for real i mean
okay um
let's see how we answer this gentleman
okay here it goes motion two or more
locations of an object we define the
word motion so that we know what we're
talking about okay so motion is two or
more locations of an object there we
have it
time comparison of two motions you have
to have two motions you have to compare
these two motions
you need memory for that in order to
have time otherwise you don't have time
and so time requires memory
motion does not you do not need
to have memory for motion
the moon was moving before we came
aboard
time
did not
exist at the time there was no such
notion as time mother nation the mother
nature does not understand time
she understands before and after
maybe because she lives at the cutting
edge of time she lives in a cross
section of time so she doesn't have this
memory to remember what came before and
after
so no there is no before and after
and so
time did not
exist i'm going to use that term
i hope you understand that i'm using it
from ordinary speech okay there was no
such notion of time mother nature does
not recognize time
that's what i mean
she lives at the cross section of time
maybe you can call that living
she lives in a single frame
at any point in time she lives in one
frame of the universal movie
and whatever's
exists at that moment in time it's all
static for her
okay that's all she she only knows the
distance between objects within a given
frame
that's all she recognizes in the
universal movie
we on the other hand we have memory
and uh that's where the problem comes in
and so motion preceded time
okay we had motion before humans and
animals and anything came aboard
we had no time
time came with memory
and there was motion before life which
is memory okay
arose on earth
animals have time they have a notion of
time an intuitive notion of time here
let me show you that okay
let me show you
a uh an example
okay this is just an example okay that
uh
animals have a notion of time and why
because
time originated with life
not with life but with uh animal life
okay with animal life that's when
timing began to exist they had an
intuitive notion of time
and what it is essentially is a
comparison of distance
versus um
again intuitive right a distance versus
speed
okay and here you have a comparison of
how an animal thinks about time why they
have an intuitive notion of time
okay here it is okay
and here let me start it here there it
goes
see you have this uh uh
little hog
okay and uh boar and you have the
lioness why does the lioness
chase the board down
well she she chases the board down
because she believes she can catch the
bore otherwise she wouldn't spend the
energy
okay here's the boar running
you know the lion linus would not even
uh
think about it if she thought she had no
chance but she when she sees the
distance and she knows more or less her
speed again she has an idea of how much
speed she has then she says okay i can
catch that
animal right that piece of food okay
and that's the uh rudimentary notion of
time you know a comparison of distance
versus speed and animals have that and
of course we took it much farther than
uh all other animals out there you know
we
uh
we we turned it into a clock
we have the ticks and we compared you
know the second hand you know on the
clock go one goes one tick mark from one
second to two second to three second
every time it goes to one second
one second you know moving one second on
one tick mark
the earth travels 30 kilometers so it's
comparing the distance
of
the distance travel
by the second hand on the clock with the
second clock the second
hand
moving one tick mark
against the motion of the earth which is
30 kilometers that's what a second is
a comparison of two motions it's a
that's what time is and nobody ever
figured it out uh they're still trying
to figure out what time is they say it's
what a clock reads
great and what is the clock it's what uh
what
reads time
yeah so we had um
we had motion before time
so when someone asks you uh when did
time begin
we could more or less give them an
answer a very qualitative answer saying
time began when life began when
animal life began began on earth on the
other hand uh motion
motion was there
since day one and so this fellow asked
uh what created motion what's an
irrational question that's what it is
okay
um why is it an irrational question
because
it's not a question of physics it's a
question of philosophy of philosophy
which is
you got to go through that first
philosophy is
explanations of purposes and reasons and
what this fellow is asking is why did
god
set the first thing in motion that's
what he's asking he's asking for the
cause of motion the original cause of
motion the first cause that's what he's
asking it's an irrational question it's
an irrational question because
you're asking
why did god do it what was his purpose
what was his reason you're not talking
about you know the physical aspect of
why something moves
if you say why did the cart move
then you have a cause you say because or
you can have a cause you can say the
donkey pulled it
so you have a cause for why
cause meaning mechanism right why the
cart moved
but if the cart is all
if if the cart's the only thing in the
universe right
and god sets it in motion
and you ask why did the cart move
the answer is because god had a headache
and he wanted to move it out of the way
that's the reason the purpose not the
cause
okay you still don't understand the
mechanism of why
of how god moved the card all you know
is that it moved and you say why did it
move move because god had a headache
wanted to get it out of the way that's
why all the answers
to why
related to
reasons and purpose
which underlie physical phenomena are
all irrational questions and the answer
is always the same because god had a
headache that's always the answer
so what this guy is asking is a rational
question now if you're asking something
else a specific motion
okay you may ask for example
why
meaning
cause mechanism why does the rope move
why does it torque
okay that's a different question now
you're talking about physics now you're
now
introducing god into the picture okay
and yeah you can say look there's a
single thread in the entire universe
underlies all matter turns into atoms
which turn into ropes which turn into
animals which turn into ropes and so on
down the line it's a single thread going
through the whole
bit of matter in the universe there's
only a single thread that underlies it
all closed loop thread okay just one
thread rubber band think of that that's
what it is okay
and yeah with that you can er
more or less get a picture of why the
rope moves why atoms move okay and here
we have the single thread hey give you
oh i thought i had it do i have it
huh i don't know what it what happened
here
okay
gotta get this one out
here it is
give me a second
got the wrong one
okay
wait till it stop starts
we have a single thread universe okay
this thread turns into ropes which turn
into atoms
which in interconnect atoms okay there
it is
all atoms are connected by these ropes
and the rows make the same atom
which binds which uh it binds
it goes from threads to rope from adam
to rope to atom and so on down the line
okay so now we can understand
why something moves in the sense that
locally like if you talk about a
specific case you can say uh
why does the rope
move why does an atom move well now we
can find out because
you're moving every time you move
something here
since it's a single closed loop thread
made of a single piece which is also
flexible okay that's the assumption
um
then when you pull here you're pulling
on a thread that's on the other side of
the universe okay the whole thing is
moving everywhere in the universe you're
pulling pushing pulling pushing okay
so uh the cause of motion for a specific
thing like an atom
uh it could be that you push the atom
you know maybe you push the ball you're
pushing the atom that's that's another
cause but when we're talking about like
the rope why does the rope torque well
again you have the atom pumping back and
forth and it torques the rope but at the
same time remember you're connected to
every atom in the universe
and so when something happens here
right like for example um
uh when the threads uh spin around and
create the magnetic field okay
that's affecting something on the other
side of the universe as well and they're
affecting us
so it's all interrelated because we're
all part of the same
string the same thread right
so yeah the the issue here is that you
cannot ask
about motion in terms of why
meaning purpose and reason
okay you can talk about in terms of
cause but not in terms of reason but if
you're going to talk about cause it's
got to be a specific case you cannot
talk about motion in general which is
what this individual asked
okay uh let's move on to another
question another issue fellow says uh i
keep getting this one
no why do i have that one i have no idea
why i have that one
oh okay i know what i had that one uh
because if you wanted to know what space
is what a void is here it is this is
what it is
that's what space looks like okay that's
what the void looks like that's what
position looks like what volume looks
like they all look like that
okay that was the issue
i forgot to mention that
okay uh here's another question another
fellow asks uh see if we get it it says
we're a discrete object a universal
object ends there is space
okay so uh here we have the spoon that i
had before and where it ends we have
space okay
uh air also but air is in space right
since we animals adam suns okay planets
are not discrete we're not discrete
where we appear to end is not space
okay so make up your mind
does the spoon end here is it discrete
or does it continue so i guess he's
referring to the ropes okay he didn't
mention that he should have put that in
there i think that's what he's referring
to just another section or manifestation
of the universal object meaning the
thread okay i guess that we are transl
that we are translated across
this
individual believes that because
every atom of the chair is bound to
every atom of the table
that they're a single object
and again is these people have mental
problems because they confuse the
context they never pay attention to the
context the context here is that the
word chair refers to that object over
there the word table belongs to this one
over here so we're going to talk about
table we're talking about a discrete
object and you say but it's connected
with the ropes so it doesn't stop there
continue
again mental problems these people have
mental problems here here let me show
you a case
here we put a spider's web there
so because i have a spider's web
connecting the chair
to the table
we have a one object there only it's the
uh what is it table spiderweb chair
object
is that what that object is
no we have three objects we say
this one's a table this one's a chair
and that one's a spider's one what part
don't you understand
i mean these people really have mental
problems and it's because you know they
i don't know if they want to sound smart
and they would be better off
you know shutting their mouths than
opening you up and you know remove all
doubts
jesus christ
okay uh fellow says
let's see what this file says this file
talks about
energy okay let's see what he just got
to say about energy
says in physics an object is an
identifiable collection of matter
which may be constrained by an
identifiable boundary and may move as a
unit by translation or rotation in
three-dimensional space
he copied that from the wikipedia
i guess all he can do is
you know uh copy and paste
he never
questioned whether these definitions
have any validity any rationality behind
it says oh it's tradition uh that's what
my teacher told me authority you know
everybody voted for a democracy
so um they used
democracy tradition
and authority to justify their
definitions only
and then he says light is an energy i
like that diabetes and energy okay i
never heard anyone talk like that in
physics by definition energies are
objects
let's see if he's got that right he says
object is an identifiable collection of
what matter
so he says enter
object is something to do with matter
and then he says according to the
definition the way he understands it
right says energies are objects
because light is an energy
well let's find out let's let's look up
the definitions to find out this guy's
even in the ballpark or he even knows
how to read or understands what he reads
okay here it is wikipedia
object a collection of matter so he got
that one right at least uh he copied it
right
yeah it's a collection of matter okay
let's see physics the natural science
that studies matter and the related
entities of energy and force
so apparently physics thinks that matter
and energy are two different things this
fellow said what he says that matter and
energy are the same thing because he
says an object is an identifiable
connection of matter he's that
light is an energy and energy are
objects so we're back to object is equal
to matter and the wikipedia says
something different says matter and
energy are two separate things you can
see they're treating them separately so
let's look at the word matter and see
what it says matter any substance that
has mass and takes up space
what is substance a form of matter
typical irrational definitions of
mathematics okay
and uh what is energy the quantitative
property
and it makes a comment there says matter
does not include energy phenomena
so this fellow does not know how to read
he just copies and pastes and he's great
copy paster you know he would work great
at a print shop right
but he doesn't do much thinking he
doesn't have much mental capacity
because he doesn't realize the
contradictions in all these definitions
and the only thing he can say is well
it's tradition
and that's what they taught me at the
monastery you know the priest the
authority
and that's what everybody voted for
democracy yeah you can see the
contradiction but it doesn't stop there
you can see the university of kansas
there says matter is the stuff that
everything is made up energy is a
property that matter has okay so energy
is not matter like he says
and just in case we get another source
uh authority source always you know
here's the
dictionary.com
and it says object anything that is
visible or tangible i like the fact that
you use anything we look up anything it
says anything
a thing of any kind what is a thing a
material object
those are the definitions these people
deal with i mean you have only
irrational definitions coming out of the
dictionaries you should never use the
ordinary dictionary for critical
definitions that make or break your
arguments
those are the ones you're going to have
to analyze and challenge before you make
yourself you know
a fool in public
okay uh so what is matter according to
dictionary.com says the substance or
substances right
of which any physical object consists of
uh or is composed you look up substance
that is
that of which a thing consists
physical matter or material so they
define matter as substance and substance
matter great we got it we got it
and what's his energy the capacity the
property of a system so energy is not
matter
so i don't know where this guy got got
the idea that energy is matter okay
nowhere does it say that again doesn't
know how to read or has mental problems
i don't know
okay here we have another oh he says ask
the question he says i wonder if bill
would call a rainbow an object
a group could point at the same rainbow
yeah you could point to a rainbow that
does not make it an object i can point
to a shadow and call it shadow and say
that's a shadow because i can point to
it does that mean it's an object no
object we point to but it's got to be an
object it doesn't mean that anything
that you can point to as an object is
that if it is an object then you can
point to it okay let's get it right okay
and so here are the arguments okay to
answer this gentleman says object that
which has shape so we have a definition
and first of all we don't have to put
any of this in the definition it's uh
understood that's that's the way it is
and here we have standalone it's got to
be a standalone object a halo is not a
an object
halo is this little plate or ring that's
on the head of an angel without the
angel all you have is a
ring or a plate
you need the angel to call it a halo
halo it has to be holy and for that you
absolutely need you know the uh the
angel same with field there's no
physical object standalone object called
field like uh
parody and maxwell said there's matter
in motion in that region we call field
okay so if you have matter in motion
field is something dynamic inside the
field whatever's in there it's moving
it's some exotic matter that's moving in
the rope model it's threads no problem
but in mathematics they just talk about
the field meaning there's nothing there
it's just this concept called field
a region of space that has a bunch of
numbers that's what field is so no
that's not a standalone object okay not
a thing
it's uh an object is not a process fire
is not an object it's not an object you
can point to object but it's a process
of combustion you can't say that because
you point to fire it's an object and
plasma is not an object it's not a thing
okay i know people say oh what do you
mean it's not a thing yes the idiots of
the electric universe who say that
plasma is a thing
that's because they never realize what
they're saying first of all they say
plasma is the fourth state of matter if
that's the definition of plasma clearly
the fourth state of matter or the fourth
state of the union or the fourth
province of argentina none of those are
physical objects okay those are concepts
that's the first issue but if uh if
plasma
is defined as ionized gas ionized is
something that's happening okay ionize
means there's something happening in
there and what it is is in general terms
it's losing an electron it could be
gaining right as well but the electrons
are floating around in a in this
soup that's in there okay this gas
that's inside
a chamber and so
plasma is ionized gas ionized gas
there's no physical object called
ionized gas there's an object called gas
there's no object called ionized okay so
it takes 10 years for a mental [ __ ]
idiot of mathematics to understand these
arguments that's why they say oh
plasma's an object okay
second it's got to have the third i mean
it has to have no motion
an object is a static concept okay and
so shadow hologram wind and what rainbow
those are dynamic concepts what you're
looking at is uh the frequency of light
okay under the rope model you have a
torsion of a rope that's what's reaching
your eye and that's why you can see
the um
the in this case the rainbow okay so
when you're looking at a shadow what you
get is ropes that are connecting to the
wall let's say the shadows on the wall
okay so what you have is uh ropes
that are extending from the atoms on the
wall to the atoms of your eye and
they're talking at torquing at a
different frequency and that's why we
call that whole image which is just some
kind of hologram a two-dimensional
hologram we call that a shadow okay
2d and 3d are both objects in science
okay in physics
uh why because they have shape 2d hash
shape 3d have shape there's nothing like
a 0d or 1d shape nothing like a 4d 5d 60
10d 26
d shape
there's only two or three d shapes they
can be squares cubes try bars whatever
and uh the nouns of ordinary speech are
not objects just because they're nouns
because they can be used as subject of a
sentence you cannot use the word motion
and say that because it's a noun because
it can be the subject of a sentence in
in ordinary speech that because of that
you can transfer
motion or punch or orbit for example and
take it into physics and say it's an
object
okay
and again
uh the context of all this the bottom
line is that we're comparing the
irrational definition of mathematics of
the religion of mathematics which is
based on see and touch on experiment
they say we got to do an experiment
what experiment are you going to do
idiot
what experiment are you going to do to
detect what what gravity is what the
mediator of gravity is if you cannot see
or touch gravity obviously
obviously you cannot go into the lab and
figure out gravity you cannot do math
you cannot do an equation and figure out
the gravity the only way is by defining
what an object is and that's which has
shape
does the mediator of gravity have shape
yes it does can you see or touch it no
you can't period we're done
in physics shape and form are synonyms
perfect synonyms there's no difference
between shape and form in the religion
of ordinary speech in mathematics
especially they make a distinction they
say shape belongs to 2d and form belongs
to 3d not in science okay it's black and
white in science we have no grave it has
to be black and white in order to
understand the uh
presenter
okay
and form is the only universal property
of all objects all objects have form but
if you think otherwise let me know of
any object that you know of that does
not have shape okay
and again i say the scientific
definition of the word object destroys
all religions i'm very proud of having
discovered
not only the definition of the word
object which is i think my greatest
achievement
more than the rope i like that the fact
that i discovered the definition of the
word object but how important it is no
one discovered how important the word
object is
no one in in 10 000 years
that's
for me that's incredible and why because
they never they never did mechanisms
what they did was
uh descriptions mathematical
descriptions
and here the question that they're
trying to answer is what is gravity
meaning you know what is that invisible
thing that's causing gravity that's what
people want to know and these people say
let me find out what the equation is
give me a hundred years
yeah sure go ahead take your 400 years
if you want
okay uh fella says here
space is nothing without the medium that
exists in it
well he should have stopped at that
first phrase there space is nothing with
or without an existing medium
space is nothing by definition there's
sin in him the two words are sin
what is space that which has no shape
synonym nothing
space is nothing period punkt
punto punto
okay and
the antonym is object what is an object
that which has shape so we have that
which has shape we compare it against
that which has no shape now we can use
these words rationally consistently in a
dissertation these are scientific
definitions very simple they have to be
very concise very simple to form the
foundations of physics
okay you can't make them complicated
they have to be as short as possible get
rid of all the unnecessary words and
just definitely get to the bottom of it
and people never realize that you have
to define very concisely and they have
all these long definitions of what
science is what physics is blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah no no
rational explanations that's science
we're done
now it's the process the study of
[Music]
okay
phil says
understanding the ether is the key to
understanding everything
so
i look up the word ether yeah it's a
bunch of particles that's what ether is
there you see it in fact i put the
little squiggly wave it's the
vibration of the ether
and what have we understood
please explain what light is
is it with the vibration of the ether is
that what how do you explain gravity
with this ether thingy
no uh mental mentally [ __ ] people
talk about the ether
okay you have to be a mental [ __ ] to
talk about ether
and what can i say you know
ether has been uh
debunked many times because ether is a
bunch of particles
and a bunch of particles do not explain
anything you cannot you cannot simulate
a single phenomenon of nature with uh
ether with a bunch of particles and if
it's not a bunch of particles because oh
no you got it wrong bill see how these
people tell me i'm wrong
they never tell me what is right tell me
tell me what the definition of ether is
and better be good okay
better be good you better have sound and
if you define it you can't use it as an
object because objects we don't define
objects we point to and name
we say tree we say rock we say floor
those are objects
so if you define
it's a concept and if it's concept you
can't say the concept vibrates
okay so you better not be able to define
the word ether okay
if you're going to use it as an object
it's a thing okay so the ether is a
concept
and it's what i said there a bunch of
particles that's what it's always been
that's what the 19th century folks were
investigating they said there's got to
be this bunch of particles that are
vibrating there and and then they ran
the uh michaelson morley experiment and
they said well no there's no bunch of
particles
because when we go in this direction go
in that direction light is the same
that's why they concluded there most of
them concluded there's no ether no bunch
of particles and then they put it in
again with space-time and with quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics what do they
say that
the ether is there alive and well
it's a bunch of particles that come in
from the void you know and they separate
into positive and negative you know
virtual particles just to make the
equation come out right and then they go
back and become nothing meaning space
meaning bunch of particles
that's the rationality of mathematical
physics okay here we have another fellow
says science is the human knowledge
my god
poor fellow okay now there's this belief
that's the definition of now it's just a
synonym of belief
when you know something you believe it
and the other guy knows something
different but he believes that and you
believe this
so you believe that god exists he
believes that god doesn't use or knows
that god doesn't exist everybody knows
everybody believes
great
so science and science is not a belief
so if knowledge is believed you can't
say science is the human knowledge no
absolutely not science rational
explanations
okay that's what science is not
knowledge has nothing to do with
now that's other than the etymology i
mean what they did was they took the
word science which meant knowledge no to
no whatever
and and they said oh science is about
knowledge absolutely not now this means
that you went to church
and you believe that's what science
knowledge means okay it means that you
believe something that you know it
you know your wife slept with your
neighbor you know absolutely know it
means you believe it because your
neighbor thinks otherwise okay and your
wife thinks otherwise
okay uh
paul says
small and large beautiful and ugly cold
and hot near and far object and space
you have created a pair of terms that
you consider complementary that is the
assertion of one generally implies the
exclusion of the other or between which
the relationship is rather one of
inversion or reciprocity your definition
of object is incomplete
in my opinion it doesn't work
i guess he meant uh it destroys his
religion because he didn't put in there
what what he's talking about i mean if
if it's incomplete please fill in the
blanks what am i missing in my
definition that which i shape
what is uh nothing that which doesn't
have shape see how easy it was what am i
missing
and until you put something in there you
know we don't know what he's talking
about what's going through his
you know between his ears he's got
zero dimensions
my god i mean they should at least learn
how to debate
you know they should make a point of
understanding how to debate in a
rational way if you're going to
criticize something put a reason an
explanation okay or you know make an
argument but to say i don't like your
definition well because it destroys your
religion no wonder you don't like it
okay last comment here we have i
understand how the rope links stretch
and contract but how do they cover vast
changes in distances
uh distance light rays coming from the
sun
uh versus in a microwave okay how do we
get similar wavelengths i wonder if the
ropes are actively sliding through atoms
that is the ropes aren't still but are
actively crisscrossing their way across
the universe closed lube thread going
from atom to atom
uh yeah uh
obviously you're not familiar completely
with the rope model
we're not saying that the rope stretches
the rope does not stretch and very
simple because if the rope stretched
you would be creating matter from the
void from nothing you'd be doing
mathematics
so the rope had better not stretch the
rope is made of a single piece and is
flexible made of a single piece and is
flexible those are the assumptions so
you're right you said it right the first
time the ropes slide
around atoms okay that's correct that
that's
that's how that's the theory that's what
we know what we call thread theory
thread theory the rope
uh unfolds into an atom converges on an
atom and one uh thread becomes part of
the proton the other thread come becomes
part of the electron shell comprises the
electron shell it's an electron shell
that encapsulates a proton stars
proton star made out of single threads
which is one of the threads of the rope
okay and so yeah when an atom moves it
slides along the rope
it doesn't and the rope doesn't stretch
it slides
like a beat on an abacus more or less
the wire doesn't travel with the bead
the bead goes along the abacus
along the wire okay so
uh you had it right there okay that's
that's how we see it we see it just like
that the rope does not stretch
okay with that i'll see you next time
and we'll see you there